is this enough to bribe you to play a
horde game blindfold it okay i'll try
it's gonna be a huge struggle to
remember where all the pawns are
but i'll try i'll play random sub this
is me blindfolded
okay good luck to resilient
oh who challenged me to casual so they
won't be farming me
okay
and we'll have to turn on
sound
each speech synthesis ready
game start d5 okay d5 wanna make sure
the clock thing is working white five
minutes zero seconds
black five minutes zero seconds
so
i had this blindfold it's a blindfold
and an ice pack
and it was in the freezer so it's really
cold right now but
uh i'll keep my
this will numb my face
okay so d5
okay
um
again the biggest challenge is just
remembering where all the pawns are
why did that not work
wait what
speech synthesis ready
why did that not work
e d takes e6 okay that works sorry about
that
i have like two um voice extension or
two ways of getting voice
d takes e6
so
we're gonna take with
uh with the d-pawn
d takes e6 okay
d4
d4 let's play
so there's no point the problem is now i
have to remember where the gaps are
so there's no pawn on d3
um
[Music]
i'll play 97. knight e7
like i'm already kind of forgetting
e5
e5 e5 okay
e5 i can take out f5
he takes f5 oh it's gonna be he takes f5
take with knight
knight takes f5 no pawn on g4 e4 d3
easier to remember what their pawns
aren't
aren't c4
wait g4 hangs h4 i think
knight takes h4
f5
wait another five knight takes f5 g
takes f5 is rough
bishop takes f5
e4
oh no wait what just happened there
knight takes f5
g takes f5 bishop takes f5 e4
there's no pawn on e3
i'm missing my knight now this is so
difficult
they're a pawn i think there's a pawn on
the e4 oh there's pawn on f3
i take up nope there's a pawn on g2 as
well
i guess i'll play bishop c8s
bishop c i'm doing well like in the
position i just don't remember where
pawns are
f4 i'll play i guess each six because
there's a pawn on g5
so i'm just gonna
h takes g5
e3
wait what
e3 e3
is there no
pawn on f
or
g takes f4 e takes f4
i agreed to do this for a very low bribe
too
[Music]
but it's a good mental challenge i guess
um so i don't have a pawn
you're doing great champ oh thank you
i just it's so hard to remember where
the pawns are
i go play rook h6 right gauge six play
g6
c6
what
okay pc6 b takes c6
b takes c6
dear b takes c6 b takes cb okay
um
i forget if there's a pawn in d5 let's
find out that i take c6
d takes c6
rick takes c6 okay
so i got rid of the thing on c6
g4
g4
i move back to
[Music]
let's play g6 g6
i think there's a pawn on f5 e5 what b5
b5
okay so that hits my rook rook f6
i hope there's no e5 or g5
he takes f6 doh
okay queen elsa queen takes f6
g3
wait gf5 oh there's no thing
ah so g3 defends
i take a
there's anything on g4
bishop takes g4 h takes g4 oh no
wait so g3 so there's no pawn on g2
queen h8
h4
[Music]
f6
b4
b4
g5 i'm in trouble
i don't know where the pawns are
i'm going to be like going around blind
with my f5
g takes h4
either pawn g3
it might be
g takes h4 wait do i still have a dark
sword bishop
queen takes h4
f3
queen each one queen takes h1 okay let's
go got my queen in
b6 v6
guess ab6 a takes b6
i still have a knight no i don't because
i took on c6
d4
d4
queen f1 queen takes f1
c5
c5
bc5 b take c5 d take c5 oh no
where's my queen queen c1 no queen
d1 no queen e1 queen takes e1
i'm scared
e5
e5 e5
uh queen
c1 no queen d1 queen takes d1
e takes f6
oh no
he takes f6
means he won queen take g5
queen takes b1
i just have to eat all the ponds before
i get mated by the ponds
so the goal is to like clean up rank by
rank g6
oh
g6 g6
queen takes a1 g7
after playing f7
king f7
g takes f8 promotes to rook check ah
funny for pointing to rook rick takes f8
okay so king r7 work on that fades b5
b5 b5
um
let's take on a2
queen takes a2
a5
i take that
no there's like a pawn in e3 i assume
no
uh let's take on b2 queen takes b2
a6
queen takes c to b6
queen b3 oh there is no pawn on b3
b7
queen a4
c6
queen takes a6
c4
yeah this is where things get like
really tricky
because white basically has a chain from
c4
i assume there's a pawn in d5
can i take on c6
man
i think i go back to a2
wait no i can't do that
now let's go back to a2
wait why can't i go back to e2
watch out he's right behind you
right b8 okay i don't know i couldn't
move back to a2 maybe i was typing c5
c5
who's right behind me
king
e7
no key six no ah
king e8
a4
what a four a4
where's my queen
rick takes b7
c takes b7 queen takes b7 f4
can i play like queen
g2
queen g2 i can oh wow
[Music]
so the diagonal five
now let's eat up the queen a2 queen a2
there's no
c6
c6
mean a5 queen takes a5 f7 check
king takes f7
f6 hi porn ziani dad
oh hi ponziani son
i
i've lost track where everything is
queen
f6 king takes f6 f5
f5
between a3 queen a3
wait did i flag
oh no it's stalemate
wait
where did all of white's pawns go
i assumed white had so many pawns
no
[Music]
i was close to flagging
i was like where are all the pawns but
they all
i really took that many pawns
i had no idea
rick takes b7 kim rosen stalemate
because at some point i just gave up
trying to keep track of where all the
pawns were
see i just assumed there were going to
be pawns like
i was also really scared seasick see
when i took an e5 i thought there might
be a pawn on before but
man at least i didn't lose
i guess i didn't realize still i guess
stalemate is a draw in this game
queen takes a5
how do we draw
a4 oh
good game
oh that was mentally intensive
wow what happened to white structure
actually blockaded nicely there
you turn off this uh
engine
back to normal
thank you amaryllis the five gifted
wait let's go through the game
no i was happy to win f5 and then h4 and
then sack
um
[Music]
oh so right why really like
oh i just hung a rook here
and then yeah the bishop takes wasn't so
good
once i got the queen in
i guess i didn't realize like i wasn't
in so much danger here
yeah this thing scared me you did so
well eric oh thank you thank you for
this oh thanks for i guess bribing me to
do this
this is a one time thing i don't think
i'm doing this again
so i would have needed to find
[Music]
wow this is actually really insane
sicilian dragon bribe sub
so this final position
black's not winning
after f5
of course like when i play queen a3 it's
stalemate
but even if i let the pawn push
i don't have time to take this pawn and
prevent the pawn from promoting
i subbed a week ago but forgot to share
hi eric smile
oh hi false lobster
return smile
so
engine gives like some weird minus .6
because i could
i could let the pawn queen
and then
this this is just a draw like there's no
is there a theoretical way for white to
win
oh white could win
so white could win also black could win
if the things were traded the way white
could win this
is
like this
oops so a black would have to under
promote to rook
and then self
checkmate
and then white could meet like this
that would be unlikely so
like
by the time
so the by the time life plays at five
it's a draw
so the way to win this is to play king
e6 oh it's like a horde end game study
and now if here i take with
wait
i don't understand this i was black
winning
oh king d6
so i go i have to win c6 and then here
here
queen here and then
i can take
and then it's yeah it's just in time
um
yeah there's some weird like
i guess end game study type positions
which are unique to horde